THIS HAS BEEN A TOUGH ST
SIX GAMES>> Joe: CARTER HART DIE
A STICK, AND SO HE UNSELFISH,
HE'S BEEN LOOKING TO PASS MORE
AND TROUBA GOT THE SHOT FROM THE
OTHER ON, NUMBER 25
FOR THE FLYERS, H SETUP
AND COULD YOU TELLIER WENT WIDE.
RISTOLAINEN,
FOX, PANARIN, CR
HE SCORES! NET.
THEY'LL GET
>> Sam: TROUBA'S OFFENSE HAS
BEEN REALLY GOODALS OF LATE.SONR
VAN RIEMSDYK.
VAN RIEMSDYK, STOPPED BY
SHESTERKIN..
>> Sam: PRPR FACING HIGH QUALITY
STARTS.
HO
RANGERS.
THEY'VE HAD SOME GOOD CHANCES,
BESIDES THETS IT ON HIS BACKHAN.
THAT.
>> Sam: THE LINESMEN AREAIN.
STROME,
>> Joe: IT'S LIKE A
ROONEY CHIPS IT OFF THE
SHOT, DONATION TO
THE SAVE AND IT'S
THIS IS JUST --
PUT IT IN THE CREASE, A ATHE FL.
>> Sam: THE FLYERS, AS JOE
MENTIONED EARLIER, 4-50 ON THE
POWER-PLAY OVER THE LAST 16ARD ,
WHO WAS WAS GOING TO
BE A A DEFLECTED
IN AND MEANWHILE, OF -- LIKE
CAM ATKINSON, GOT OFF TO A GREAT
START, RIGHT.
>> Sam: YES.
>> Joe: ONE G IT. JOE.
>> Joe: BEEN ALL OVER THE PLACE.
BOY, HE HAD A GREAT CHANCE.
RANG WAY, WAY